[MUSIC]
LEAD is different from
other online courses,
because it really gives you a lot in
terms of interaction with your peers,
teaching assistants, but,
mostly, with the professors.
That interaction with the professors,
to me,
is what completely sets LEAD
apart from other online courses.
>> Never have I faced an issue where I
wanted to reach out to the faculty but
I was not able to.
And they were pretty responsive, and
kind enough to answer my
questions with elaborate answers.
>> When I got exposed to the faculty
that Stanford is famous for,
it was beyond impressive.
>> There's a lot of cases
where you have live sessions.
And you can obviously
communicate that way.
But there was also a lot of
discussions in the forums, or
even one on one email dialogs.
And so you definitely had a lot a support
and you feel pretty connected to, and
engaged, and committed to the classes.
>> You have access to this information,
and also this exchange is in such
enriching experiences that any
other program did not experience.
>> Often, I've actually used case studies
or questions that I got the day before or
that I saw the day before
in the lead program.
And then I would come across something at
work and I could immediately apply it.
>> The courses are designed such that they
give you the right tools, techniques and
framework, which you can take and
apply in your career.
You can do it at your own pace.
At your own convenient time.
>> LEAD is probably the best learning
experience they can get outside an MBA,
if they're interested in learning about
business and leadership practices.
>> It's not so
much about the certificate or the degree.
It's much about the skills
that I acquire here.